foreign
folks in 2022 we know capitalism has a
problem
the system that undergirds much of our
way of life in the west is exacerbating
Injustice and inequality
we know that women still get paid less
than men this is 2022.
and the share of the bottom half of the
world's population and wealth is just
two percent
we know that the playing field is not
level
and yet
even as we are Awash in new ideas and
thinking and approaches Technologies and
gadgets we somehow do not seem to know
how to address the fundamental problems
at the heart of it all
now I can't claim to have all the
answers but today I want to talk to you
about a tool that can help us design
more just systems
and that tool is moral clarity now moral
Clarity is not an ideology
it's not righteousness moral Clarity is
doing the right thing because it is
right and not from fear of sanction or
in expectation of a reward it is Clarity
of the demands that we are allowed to
make of others
it is to never confuse what we ought to
do with what we can do
no one
ought to starve no one ought to be
discriminated against no one
ought to profit from suffering
these are not personal preferences these
are moral imperatives that most people
believe in
whatever their politics or culture
and this is what gives us the basis to
build more just organizations
communities and ultimately a more just
word
so folks how do we do it first
if we want Justice let's use the
language of Justice the language of
right and wrong take stakeholder
capitalism this notion that a company is
responsible to all its stakeholders and
to the environment and not just its
shareholders
how well has it done
well we have data that shows that as a
group companies that subscribe to
stakeholder capitalism did no better
supporting their employees in the
pandemic than companies that made no
such pledge
why
it's not because stakeholder capitalism
is a charade or its ends are not Noble
or its metrics broken or incentives
misaligned it's because we have been
selling stakeholder capitalism as a way
to reduce risk and ensure long-term
growth and profits
take for instance
why should a workplace be diverse
and this is what I hear all the time so
it better reflects our customers
allowing us to build better products so
we can improve retention so we can
increase Innovation and profit
all right but what if you already have
record-setting profits what if your
products are already all the rage what
when there are far easier alternatives
to increasing profits than the difficult
work of organizational change what then
what then will motivate us to stay the
course
so folks I need you let's come together
and set the narrative straight here
let's say it is loud and clear
we want every workplace to affirm women
minorities and every group that is
underrepresented not an expectation of
more Innovation or profit or retention
but because it is the right thing to do
it is the just thing to do because that
is what we ought to do
now I'm not minimizing the difficulty of
organizational change I run an
organization I understand the competing
demands and priorities
reconciling what we ought to do with
what we can do is necessarily imperfect
moral Clarity is not moral perfection it
is moral alertness
I'm also not minimizing or saying that
Innovation or better products or
retention are not worthy goals my point
is let's start making space in our
organizations for moral language and
clear moral arguments
now
there was a Time in America
when you could start as a custodian or
in the mail room and Rise through the
ranks even to the top job
now that doesn't happen anymore
we have outsourced those jobs we have
turned them into gig work
and the problem is not just the low
wages or poor benefits or the
unpredictable working hours
the problem is
been on nothing nothing about the lives
of so many who make our own possible
we don't know that the worker in our
cafeteria is sleeping in her car so she
can work three jobs to send her kids to
college
we don't know that the worker in our
warehouse has uncontrolled diabetes even
though he has health insurance but he
doesn't have the time to manage his
chronic condition folks how can we be
just if these indignities are hidden
from us if they don't show up in our
accounting
how can lives matter truly matter to us
if we only read about them if we don't
encounter them if we don't share in
their Humanity
so it shouldn't take a hot labor market
for us to invest in our entry-level
employees
and let's not stop at tuition subsidies
and training let's do the harder work
of mentoring those who do not show up on
our organizational charts
let's understand their aspirations and
connect them to Opportunities even if
those are Outsider firms
next
let's get rid of the idea that a smart
app or Gadget or technology or business
model will fix Injustice it will not
Justice requires accompaniment
staying by a person's side until right
is done
I started a non-profit that provides
Health Care to the rural poor in India
and we realized very early on that we
could have all the Therapeutics and
healthcare workers and Facilities but we
would not transform outcomes until we
accompanied literally our patients so
in our maternal and neonatal health
program expectant mothers have us on
speed dial they call us as soon as they
go into labor and we stay beside them
literally till they make it to the
delivery room in time why
because the barriers are too numerous to
predict
flooded roads and unwilling patriarch a
labor nurse who will not assist a woman
of another caste
and that is why
we journey to distant cities if we have
to and we find a neonatal ICU and stay
by the side of an anxious mother and her
newborn until they are both well
and that is how we have got mortality
rates in half in our program when
everyone around us told us that it was
impossible
accompaniment is not just about health
care
in the United States low-income students
drop out of community colleges at record
rates because of the barriers they face
they may not have the fare for public
transport to attend classes they may not
have the child care to make it to a job
interview they may be struggling with
homelessness or hunger
now financial assistance is crucial and
we need more of it but it will not by
itself transform outcomes what we also
need are seasoned advisors who can
accompany our students who can help them
pick majors and classes teach them study
techniques provide career counseling and
help them juggle home work and college
and now we have rigorous evidence that
these accompaniment-centered
interventions that address a whole array
of barriers can double double graduation
rates this is from the city University
of New York's ASAP initiative
accompaniment is not just for
non-profits
as we try to reimagine
and reconfigure work
and inclusion in the wake of the
pandemic accompaniment is that
principled approach that can get us
there
now for all of these ideas to take root
and endure we need to make moral Clarity
foundational to our educational system a
recent College poll showed that
graduating college students consider
working for social change less less
likely than they did as Freshmen
our students spend all their time
becoming skilled specialists
they accrue credentials for everything
except for the difficult work of making
the world just
I teach a course entrepreneurship for
the idealist at Princeton University
which trains students in moral Clarity
so they can go out and make the world
just
we can teach our students the language
of right and wrong and give them the
courage to user we can teach them the
nature of Injustice so they have a
Fighting Chance at dismantling it
and we can train them in accompaniment
we don't expect families to train
humanists or scientists or engineers
so let's stop making moral Clarity the
sole responsibility of families or of
religion
now some of you may be thinking that all
of this is too hard
that this is unrealistic
and I can understand that I've been
doing this a long time
let's stop worrying about being
realistic
last year folks we invested
621 billion dollars globally in startups
in dreams in Visions in visions of
Worlds transformed by new technologies
in visions of planets colonized and of
alternate universes now many of those
dreams will fail
many of those dreams will take decades
to materialize but will we flinch
no
we'll Double Down such as our faith in
those Visions folks if we are trying to
do something truly hard
I want us to come together to do the
hardest thing there is
and vision and then build a just world
not a prosperous world not a
frictionless world not a resilient world
but a just word
now in our time the call to do the right
thing because it is right because it is
just
evokes a certain blissfulness
it has that quality of a one's beloved
Melody
whose notes now elude us
we are worried that if we sing the tune
it's going to land just a bit flat in
our time
and the reason is
the foundational myth of our political
and economic systems that people will do
only that
which is advantageous to them
so while we never shun our idealism it's
a stubborn thing
we learn early on to wear it lightly
folks
let's stop selling ourselves short
we are capable of being small but we are
not small beings
we help strangers whom we know we will
never see again
we grieve
we grieve for strangers who are oceans
away
in the expectation of what reward our
polish mothers leaving their strollers
on train stations so Ukrainian mothers
fleeing dispossessed and broken will
find some respite
yes we are driven by incentives
but we are also driven by love
Mercy kindness Justice solidarity
folks
I have an Abiding Faith in our idealism
in mind and in yours and here's why
are Pursuits may be different
our politics may be different
our motivations will always be many
but our deepest longing
has always been the same
to find our Humanity
to Fathom that magnificent vastness
within each of us thank you
[Applause]